there is no justification for the horror
that Hamas Unleashed against innocent
men women children and babies on the 7th
of October supporting Israel is
essential and aiding civilians in Gaza
is essential too the humanitarian
situation is dire the death toll and the
suffering of Palestinian civilians is
tragic Hamas is clearly using innocent
Palestinians and hostages as human
Shields and our hearts bleed at the
images of small children pulled out from
under the rubble so while Israel has the
right to fight Hamas it is also
essential that it strives to avoid
civilian casualties and to be as
targeted as possible because every human
life matters be it Israeli or
Palestinian two weeks ago we had already
tripled our Aid to Gaza today I can
announce that we are further increasing
the humanitarian Aid to Gaza by another
25 million euros and at the same time
we're working on complimentary routes a
maritime corridor from Cypress for
example that would guarantee a sustained
regulated and robust flow of Aid our
Union is the largest humanitarian donor
to and we will keep pushing for our Aid
to reach civilians in need this can make
the difference between life and death
for thousands of
Palestinians as we deal with the urgency
of
today we must also make the effort to
think about tomorrow and I know all of
you as allies to imagine what a lasting
peace may look like yes and even in
these times to restore hope for
Palestinians and Israelis and for this
they need a perspective and the
perspective is the two-state solution of
course in the end Israelis and
Palestinians have to agree they have to
agree on the way forward but I believe
we as a part of the international effort
must also contribute we have a role to
play by putting forward some basic
principles for example for the day after
that could help find Common Ground first
of all Gaza can can be no safe heaven
for terrorists second this implies that
the terrorist organization Hamas cannot
control or govern Gaza there should be
only one Palestinian Authority and one
Palestinian State third there can be no
long-term Israeli security presence in
Gaza Gaza is an essential part of any
future Palestinian State fourth no for
fored displacement of Palestinians from
Gaza and finally no sustained blockade
of Gaza any future Palestinian state
must be viable also from an economic
point of view and Europe stands ready to
work with all people and countries in
this region to make this
happen